يا ايها الذين امنوا قاتلوا الذين يلونكم
من الكفار وليجدوا فيكم غلضه واعلموا ان
الله مع المتقين صدق الله العظيم انتصارا
لمظلوم الشعب الفلسطيني وضمن الرد على
العدوان الامريكي البريطاني على بلدنا
نفذت القوات البحريه في القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه وبعون الله تعالى عمليتين
عسكريتين في البحر الاحمر الاولى استهدفت
سفينه امريكيه ستار ناسيا والاخرى استهدفت
سفينه بريطانيه مورنينج تايد وقد تم
استهداف السفينتين بصواريخ بحريه مناسبه
وكانت الاصابات دقيقه ومباشره بفضل الله
وستقوم القوات المسلحه اليمنيه بتنفيذ
المزيد من العمليات العسكريه النوعيه ضد
كافه الاهداف المعاديه الامريكيه
والبريطانيه في البحرين الاحمر والعربي
وذلك ضمن حق الرد المشروع على العدوان
ودفاعا عن اليمن العزيز وشعبه المجاهد ان
القوات المسلحه اليمنيه تؤكد على استمرار
عملياتها العسكريه في البحرين الاحمر
والعربي ضد الملاحه الاسرائيليه او
المتجهه الى موانئ فلسطين المحتله حتى رفع
الحصار وايقاف العدوان على الشعب
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه والله حسبنا ونعم
الوكيل نعم المولى ونعم النصير عاش اليمن
حرا عزيزا مستقلا والنصر لليمن ولكل احرار
الامه صنعاء ال 26 من رجب
1445 للهجره الموافق للسادس من فبراير
2024 صادر عن القوات المسلحه